it's my honor as well as my privilege to
welcome our lifetime's best long-term
investor Mr Warren
Buffett 1 million 2 million 3
million seems to be working
uh I'd like to just say a few words uh
preliminarily and then uh uh the
Highlight for me will be getting your
questions in in in a few minutes because
uh that's I want to talk about what's on
your mind I urge you to throw hard balls
it's it's it's more fun for me if you uh
if you put a little uh put a little
speed on the pitches as they come in
that you can ask about anything except
last week's Texas A&M game that's off
limits uh we have a couple men here from
sunrust I was just up at the c meeting
uh and I sit next to Jimmy Williams
there who ran Sun Trust for many years
and uh uh he wanted to be sure that I
wore this sunrust shirt down here I've
tried to get sponsorship on the senior
golf store I haven't had much luck but
now on the banker store I'm doing a
little bit better and he said I got a
percentage of the increase in deposits
and gains though so all go out for
sunrust dear old sunrust uh I would like
to talk for just one minute to the
students about your about your future
when you leave here because there's
you're going to learn a tremendous
amount about Investments uh and you'll
learn you'll learn enough to do well you
you've all got the IQ to do well you've
all got the initiative and energy to do
well or you wouldn't be you wouldn't be
here uh and most of you will succeed in
in in in in meeting your aspirations uh
but in in determining whether you
succeed uh there's more to it than
intellect and energy and I'd like to
talk for just a second about that in
fact there was a fellow that Pete kwood
in alaha used to say that he looked for
three things in hiring people look for
integrity intelligence and energy and he
said if the the person didn't have the
first two that the latter two would kill
them because if they don't have
integrity you want them dumb and lazy
you don't want them smart and
energetic and I I really like to talk
about that first one CU we we know
you've got the second two and and I play
along with me in a little for just a
second uh in terms of thinking about
that question uh you've all been here I
I guess almost all of your second year
mbas and you've got to know your
classmates and think for a moment that I
granted you the right to buy
10% of one of your classmates for the
rest of his or her
lifetime um now you can't pick one with
a rich father that doesn't count I mean
you've got to uh you've got to pick them
pick somebody who's going to do it on
their own Merit and and I gave you an
hour to think about it
which one are you going to pick among
all your classmates is for the one you
want to own 10% of for the rest of their
lifetime uh are you going to give an IQ
test pick the one with the highest IQ I
doubt it are you going to pick the one
with the best
grades uh I doubt it uh you're not even
going to pick the most energetic one
necessarily or the one that displays the
most initiative but you're going to
start looking for qualitative factors in
addition because everybody's got enough
brain there and and enough energy and I
would say that if you thought about it
for an hour decided who you're going to
place that bet on you'd probably pick
the one who you responded the best to
because the one that was going to have
the leadership qualities the one that
was going to be able to get other people
to carry out their interests and that
would be the person who was generous and
honest and who gave credit to other
people even if for their own ideas all
kinds of qualities like that and you
could write down those qualities that
you admire in this other person whoever
you admire most in the
class and then I would throw in a hooker
I would say as part of 10% of this
person you had to agre to go short 10%
of somebody else in the
class that's more fun isn't it and you
think well now who do I want to go short
of and uh uh again you wouldn't pick the
person with the lowest IQ or the or you
you would you would start thinking about
the person really who turned you off for
one reason or another I mean they had
very various qualities quite apart from
their academic achievement but they had
various quality in the IND you should
really want to be around them and other
people didn't want to be around them and
what were the qualities that lead to
that
well there'd be a whole bunch of things
you know but it's the person who's
egotistic all the person who's greedy
the person who slightly dishonest Cuts
Corners all of these qualities and you
can write those down on the right hand
side of the page and when you look at
that we'll just I don't know which one
I'm using can you hear me okay with this
fine yeah micophone to the side back up
what do I do with
it it just came loose oh it just came
loose okay
you can see why I avoid technology
that's chewing gum is about as far as I
get uh as you looked at those qualities
on the left and right hand side there's
one interesting thing about them it's
not the ability to throw a football 60
yards uh it's not it's not the ability
to run the 100 yard dash in 93 it's not
being the best looking person in the
class they're all qualities that if you
really want to have the ones on the
left-and side you can have them I mean
they are they qualities of behavior
temperament character that that are
achievable they're not forbidden to
anybody in this group and if you look at
the qualities on the right hand side the
ones that you find turn you off in other
people there's not a there's not a
quality there that you have to have if
you have it you can you can you can you
can get rid of it and you can get rid of
a lot easier at your age than you can at
my age because uh most behavior is is
Habitual and they say the chains of
habit are too light to be felt until
they're too heavy to be broken and
there's no question about it I see
people people with these
self-destructive Behavior patterns at my
age or even 10 or 20 years younger and
they really are entrapped by them they
they go around and they do things that
turn off other people uh right and left
and uh uh they don't need to be that way
but by a certain point they get so they
can hardly change it but at your age you
can have any any any habits any any
patterns of behavior that you wish it's
simply a question of which you decide
and why not decide the ones that I mean
if you like Ben Graham did this Ben
Franklin did it before him but Ben Ben
Graham and his low in his low teens
looked around and he looked at the
people he admired and he said you know I
want to be admired so why don't I just
behave like them and he found there was
nothing impossible about behaving like
them and similarly he he did the same
thing on the reverse side in terms of
getting rid of those qualities so I
would suggest that if you write those
qualities down and think about them a
little while and make them habitual you
will be the one that you want to buy 10%
of when you get all through and the
beauty of it is you already own 100%
you're stuck with it so you might as you
might as well be that person as somebody
else well that's that's a short little
sermon so let's get on to what uh what
you're interested in and uh like I say
you can you can go all over the lot so I
don't know exactly how we're going to
handle this but uh but uh let's start
with a hand here someplace or
other where do we go with the first one
yeah right here your thoughts about
Japan my thoughts about Japan I I'm I'm
not a macro guy now I say to myself
Burks your halfway way can borrow money
for 10 years at 1% in Japan now 1% and I
say to myself gee I took Graham's class
45 years ago and i' been working hard at
this thing all my life maybe I can earn
more than 1% you know if I really worked
hard at it 1% any doesn't seem
impossible does it so I wouldn't want to
get involved in currency risk so I'd
have to do it in something that was Yen
denominated so I have to get I have to
be in Japanese real estate or a Japanese
business or something of the sort and
beat and all I have to do is beat 1%
that's all the money's going to cost and
I can get it for 10 years uh so far I
haven't found anything
that uh it's it's it's kind of
interesting the the Japanese companies
earn very low Returns on equity and and
uh uh they have a bunch of businesses
that earn four five 6% on equity and
it's very hard to earn a lot as an
investor when the business you're in
doesn't earn very much money now now
some people do it in fact I've Got a
Friend Walter schlass who worked with
graham at the same time I did and
and it was the first way I went at
stocks to buy stocks selling way below
working capital very cheap quantitative
stocks I call it the cigar butt approach
to investing is that you walk down the
street and you look around for a cigar
butt someplace and you finally you see
one and it's soggy and kind of repulsive
but there's one puff left in it so you
pick it up and the puff is free I mean
it's a cigar butt stock I mean you get
one free puff out of it and then you
throw it away and you walk down the
street try to find another
one I mean it's not elegant
but it work you know if if you're
looking for a free puff uh it works
those are low return businesses but time
is the friend of the wonderful business
it's the enemy of of the lousy business
if you're in a lousy business for a long
time you're going to get a lousy result
even if you buy it cheap if you're in a
wonderful business for a long time even
if you pay a little too much going in
you're going to get a wonderful result
if you stay in a long time I find very
few wonderful businesses in Japan at
present now that uh they may change the
culture in some way so that that the
managements get more stockholder
responsive over there and returns are
higher but at the present time you'll
find a very lot of low return businesses
and that was true even when the Japanese
economy was booming I mean it's it's
amazing they had a incredible Market
without incredible companies uh they
were incredible in terms of doing a lot
of business but they weren't incredible
in terms of the return on Equity that
and that they achieved uh uh and that's
finally caught up with them so we have
so far done nothing there but as long as
money is 1% I'll keep looking I mean
that
yeah
yeah you were rumored to be one of the
rescue buyers of long-term capital what
what was the play there what did you see
well there's a story in the current
Fortune Magazine when it has rert
Murdoch's picture on the cover that
tells the whole story of our involvement
it's kind of an interesting story
because I all I it's it's a long story
so I won't go into all the background of
it but I got the really serious call
about long-term
capital uh proba what four weeks ago
this Friday whenever it was it was my
granddaughter I got it in midafternoon
and my granddaughter was having her
birthday party that evening and then I
was flying that night to Seattle to go
on a 12-day trip with Gates on a to
Alaska and a private train all kinds of
things where I was really out of
communication but I got this call on a
Friday afternoon saying that things were
really getting serious there I'd had
some other calls before that the article
gets into a few weeks earlier I know
those people most of them pretty well a
lot of them were Solomon when I was
there and uh the place was imploding and
the Fed was sending people up that
weekend and so between that
Friday and the following Wednesday when
the New York
fed um in effect orchestrated a uh uh a
rescue effort but without any federal
money involved uh I was quite active but
I was having this terrible time because
we were sailing up through these U
through these Canyons which held no
interest for me whatsoever in Alaska and
and the captain would say you know if we
just steer over here we might see some
bear in Wales and I said steer where you
got a good satellite connection cuz
I so so it was uh in fact there's a
picture of for where I've got my Old
Faithful is going off behind me and I've
got my back to it I'm on the phone which
was the people the group thought was
kind of funny the way I was working the
phone but we put in a bit on on on
Wednesday morning I was by then I was in
uh bowan
Montana and I talked to uh Bill mcdonal
the head of the New York fed about uh
about 10:00 they were having an eve
bankers at 10:00 that morning in in New
York and I caught him right we actually
delivered a message to him he called me
out there in Wyoming a little bit
before1 New York time and we made a bid
it was a it was uh because it was being
done at a long distance and everything
it was really the outline of a bid but
uh in the
end uh it was a bid for 250 million
essentially for the net assets of uh but
we would have put in three and 3/4
billion on top of that and it would have
been three billion from birkshire
halfway 700 million from AIG and 300
million from Goldman Sachs and we
submitted that but we put a very short
time fuse on it because when you're
bidding out100 billion doar worth of
Securities that are moving around you
don't want to leave a fixed price bid
out there very long plus we were worried
about it getting shopped uh in the end
they the bankers made the deal and uh uh
but it was an it was an interesting
period the whole long-term Capital
Management and I hope most of you are
familiar with it but the whole story is
really fascinating because if you take
joh Merryweather and Eric Rosenfeld
Larry Helen brand Greg Hawkins Victor
agani the two Nobel Prize winners Merton
scholes if you take the 16 of
them that they probably have as high an
average IQ as any 16 people working
together in one business in the country
including at Microsoft or or wherever
you want to name so that incredible
amount of intellect in that room now you
combine that with the fact that those 16
had had extensive experience in the
field they were operating I mean this
these this were was not a bunch of guys
who had made their money you know
selling men's clothing and then all of a
sudden went into the Securities business
or anything they had had they they' had
in aggregate the 16 had probably had 350
or 400 years of experience doing exactly
what they were doing and then you throw
in the third factor that most of them
had virtually all of their very
substantial net worths in the business
so they had their own money up hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars of
their own money up so super high
intellect working in a field they knew
and essentially they went
broke and that to me is absolutely
fascinating I mean I I if I ever write a
book it's going to be called why smart
people do dumb things my partner says it
should be autobiographical but I but but
this might be an interesting
illustration and these are perfectly
decent guys I you know I I I I respect
them and they helped me out when I was
had problems with Solomon and so they
they they are not bad people at all but
to make money they didn't have and
didn't need they risked what they did
have and did need and that's foolish
that is just plain foolish I doesn't
make any what your IQ is if you if you
risk something that is important to you
for something that is unimportant to you
it just does not make any sense I don't
care whether the odds are 100 to one
that you succeed or a thousand to one
that you succeed if you hand me a gun
with a th Chambers a million Chambers in
it and there's a bullet in one chamber
and you said put it up your temple how
much do you want to be be paid to pull
it once I'm not going to pull it you
know you can name any sum you want but
it doesn't do anything for me on the
upside and I think the downside is
fairly
clear so I'm not interested in that kind
of a game and yet people do it
financially and without thinking about
it very much uh there was a great book
it wasn't a great book it was a great
title there was a lousy book written
once with a great title uh by Walter
Gutman the title was you only have to
get rich once now that seems pretty
fundamental doesn't it what is what
difference if you've got $100 million at
the start of the year and you're you're
going to make 10% if you're unleveraged
and 20% if you're leveraged 99 times out
of 100 what difference does it make at
the end of the year whether you got 110
million or 120 million makes no
difference at all I mean if you if you
die at the end of the year you know the
guy that writes up the story may make a
typo and he may say 110 even if he had
120 so you g nothing at all you know
what it can't it makes absolutely no
difference makes no difference to your
family makes no difference to anything
and yet the downside
particularly managing other people's
money is not only losing all your money
but it's it's disgrace and humiliation
and and facing friends whose money
you've lost and everything I I just I
just can't imagine an equation that that
makes sense for and yet 16 guys with
very high IQs who are very decent people
entered into that game and you know I
think it's Madness and it's it's it's
produced by an overreliance to some
extent on things you know those guys
would tell me back when I was at Solomon
you know that a Six Sigma event wouldn't
you know wouldn't wouldn't touch us or a
seven Sigma EV but they were wrong I
mean that there history does not tell
you the probabilities of future
Financial things happening and they had
a great Reliance on mathematics and they
felt that that the baate of the stock
told you something about the risk of a
stock it doesn't tell you a damn thing
about the risk of a stock in my view and
uh uh and and do not tell you about the
risk of going broke in in my view uh and
maybe in their view now too uh but but I
you know I I don't I don't like to even
use them as an example because they are
I mean the same thing in a different way
could happen to any of us probably where
we where we really have a blind spot
about something that's crucial because
we know a whole lot about something else
it's like Henry Kaufman said the other
day that the people that are going broke
in this situation are just two of two
types the ones who knew nothing and the
ones that knew everything
and uh it's it's it's it's sad in a way
I urge you in anything we never
basically borrow money I mean we we got
float through our insurance business and
to do things but I never borrowed money
I never borrowed money when I had 10,000
bucks basically because what difference
did it make I was having fun as I went
along and it didn't make any difference
whether I had $10,000 or a million
dollar or $10
million uh you know except if I had a
medical emergency or something had come
along like that but I was going to I was
going to do the same things when I had a
lot of money is when I had very little
money you know if you think about the
difference between me and you in terms
of how we live you know we wear the we
wear the same clothes basically Sun
Trust gives me mine but
you what we so we wear the same clothes
we we we eat you know we we all have a
chance to drink the juice of the Gods
here but we we all go to McDonald's or
better yet Dairy Queen and uh and we we
live in a house that's that's that's
warm and winter and cool and summer and
and and we watch uh Nebraska Texas had
am on a big screen you know you you see
it the same way I see it we do
everything Our Lives aren't that
different you know that you'll get
decent medical care if something happens
to you and I'll get decent Medical Care
the only thing we do is we travel
differently you know I ride around this
little plane I love
it and that takes money but if you leave
if you leave that aside if you leave
that we travel differently but other
than travel you know I would I think
about it think what what can I do that
you can't do now I get to work in a job
that I love but I've always worked in a
job I love I loved it when I and I loved
it just as much when I you know when it
was a big deal if I made a thousand
bucks and I urged you to work in jobs
you love I mean I think you're out of
your mind if you take keep taking jobs
that you don't like because you think
it'll look good on your resume I was
with a fellow at Harvard the other day
who was taking me over to talk and he
was 28 and he was telling me a lot what
he done in life and which was terrific
and and then I said what are you going
to do next and he said well he said
after I get out my my uh MBA he said I
think maybe I to go to work for a
management consulting firm because it'll
look good on my resume I said what
you've been 28 you've been doing all
these things I mean you got a resume
that's 10 times as good as anybody I've
ever seen it I said if you take another
job you don't like just for I said isn't
that a little like saving up sex for
your old age you know I mean there comes
a time when you ought to just start
doing what you know
you so
I I think I got the point across to him
H uh but I you ought to take a job when
you get out here take a job you love
don't take a job that you know you think
it's going to look good on your resume
take take a job you love you may change
it later on but you'll jump out of bed
in the morning I mean when I got out
when I got out of Columbia the first
thing I tried to go to work for Graham
immediately I offered to go to work for
him for nothing he said I was overpriced
but but but I kept pestering I went out
to Al and I sold Securities for three
years and I kept writing him and giving
him ideas and doing all these finally I
went to work for him for a couple years
and and and uh it was a great experience
but I
always really worked in a job I worked
in a job that that I would that I you
know love doing and you should really
take a job that if you were
independently wealthy you would take
that's the that's the job to take
because that's the one that you're going
to have great fun in you'll learn
something you'll be excited about it and
you can't miss you may go do something
else later on but but uh you'll get way
more out of it and I don't care what the
starting salary is or anything of the
sort uh uh I don't know how I got off on
that but I uh there I am uh so I I I do
think that
that if you think you're going to be a
lot happier if you've got 2x instead of
X you're probably making a mistake I
mean it uh uh you you ought to you ought
to find something you like that's that
works with that and if and you'll get in
trouble if if you think that making 10x
or 20x is the answer to everything in
life because then you will do things
like borrow money when you should or or
maybe cut corners on on things that your
employer wants you to cut corners on it
just doesn't make any sense you won't
like it when you look back on
it yeah would you talk to the students
about the companies that you like I
don't mean names I mean what makes the
company you like I like I like
businesses I can understand we'll start
with that that narrows it down about 90%
I mean see I there's all kinds of things
I don't understand but fortunately
there's enough I do understand and you
got this big wide world out there almost
every company's public owned so he got
he got all American Business practically
available to you now to start with
doesn't make sense to go with things
that you think you can understand but
you can understand some things I can
understand this I mean you can
understand this anybody can understand
this I mean this is a product that
basically hasn't been changed much they
added the Cherry uh but you know since
1886 or whatever it was and it's a
simple business it's it's not an easy
business I don't want a business that's
easy for competitors so I want a
business with a mo around it I want a
very valuable castle in the middle and
then I want to I want to I I I want the
Duke who's in charge of that castle to
be honest and hardworking and able and
then I want a big moat around the castle
and that moat can be various things the
moat in a business like our auto
insurance business at Geico is low cost
I mean people have to buy auto insurance
so everybody's going to have one auto
insurance policy per per car basically
per driver and
and I can't sell them 20 you know but
but they have to buy one when are they
going to buy it on they're going to buy
it on based on service and cost most
people will assume the service is
fairly uh identical among companies or
close enough so they're going to do it
on cost so I got to be the lowc cost
producer that's my Mo to the extent my
costs get further lower than the other
guy I've thrown a couple of sharks into
the moat you know but all the time if
you've got a wonderful Castle there are
people out there going to try and attack
it and take it away from you and I want
a castle that I can understand but I
want a castle with a motor on it 30
years ago East kodak's moat was was just
as wi as Coca-Cola's moat I mean if you
were going to take a picture of your
six-month-old baby and you're going to
want to look at that picture 20 years
from now and you're going to look at it
50 years from now and you're never going
to get a chance I mean you're not a
professional photographer so that you
can evaluate what's going to look good
20 or 50 years ago what is in your mind
about that about that photography
company is what counts because they are
promising you that the picture you take
today is going to be terrific to look at
20 or 30 or 50 years from now about
something that's very important to you
maybe your own child or whatever it may
be well Kodak had that in Spades 30
years ago they owned that they had what
I call share of mind forget about share
of market share of mind they had
something in everybody's mind around the
country around the world with a little
yellow box and everything that said
Kodak is the best that's priceless
they've lost some of that they haven't
lost at all and and not due to George
fiser runs George is doing a great job
but they let that moat narrow they let
Fuji come and start narrowing the moat
in various ways they let them get into
the Olympics and take away that special
aspect that only only Kodak was fit to
photograph the Olympics so Fuji gets
there and immediately in people's minds
Fuji becomes more an a parody with with
Kodak you haven't seen that with Co K's
mod is wider now than it was 30 years
ago you can't see the moat day by day
but every time you know the
infrastructure gets built in some
country that isn't yet profitable for
Coke but will be 20 years from now the
mod is widening a little bit the things
are all the time changing that mode in
One Direction or another 10 years from
now you can see the difference our
managers of the businesses we run i'
I've got one message to them you know
which is to widen the mod and we want to
we want to throw crocodiles and sharks
and everything else Gators I guess into
into the moat to keep away competitors
and that that's comes about through
service it comes about through quality
of product it comes about through cost
it comes about sometimes through patents
it comes about through real estate
location so that's the business I'm
looking for now what kind of businesses
am I going to find like that well I'm
going to find them I'm going to find
them in simple products because I'm not
going to be able to figure out what the
Mo's going to look like for Oracle or
Lotus or Microsoft 10 years from now I
mean I Gates is the best businessman
I've ever run into and you know they've
got a hell of a position but I really
don't know what that business is going
to look like 10 years from now and I
certainly don't know what his
competitor's businesses are going to
look like 10 years from now now I'll
name one I don't own I know what the
chewing gum business is going to look
like from 10 years from now I mean the
internet is not going to change how we
chew gum it's and and nothing much else
is going to change that we chew gum and
then are there going to be lots of new
products is it really you know our
spearmint Juicy Fruit and all those
going to evaporate some isn't going to
happen you give me a billion dollars and
tell me to go in the chewing gum
business and try and make a real dent in
regle I can't do it and that's the way I
think about business I say to myself
give me a billion dollars and how much
can I hurt the guy give me $10 billion
give me $10 billion and how much can I
hurt Coca-Cola around the world I can't
do it well those are good businesses Now
give me some money and tell me to hurt
somebody in in some other fields and I
can figure out how to do it uh so I want
a simple business easy to understand
great economics now honest en able
management and and uh then I can see
about in a general way where they're
going to be 10 years from now and if I
can't see where they're going to be 10
years from now I don't want to buy it
basically I don't want to buy any stock
where if they close the New York Stock
Exchange tomorrow for 5 years I won't be
happy owning it I buy a farm and I don't
get a quote on it for 5 years and I'm
happy the farm does okay you know I buy
an apartment house don't get a quote on
it for 5 years I'm happy if the
apartment house produces the returns
that I expect but people buy a stock and
they look at the price the next morning
and they decide whether they're doing
well or not doing well it's it's crazy
because they're buying a piece of a
business that's what Graham the most
fundamental part of what he taught me
you know you're not buying a stock
you're buying a you're buying a part
ownership in a business you will do well
if the business does well and if you
didn't pay a totally silly price and
that's what it's all about and you ought
to buy businesses you understand just
like if you're buying Farms you ought to
buy Farms you understand it it's it's
not
complicated uh in in calling this gr and
Buffet I mean it's just pure gram I I I
was very fortunate because I I picked up
a book when I was 19 I got interest in
stocks when I was about six or seven and
I bought my first stock when I was 11
but I was playing around with all this
stuff and I had charts and volume and
I'm making all kinds of technical
calculations everything and then I
picked up a little book and it just said
that you're not buying some little
ticker symbol that bounces around every
day you're you're buying a part of the
business and soon as I started thinking
about it that way everything else swed
very simple so we buy businesses we
think we can understand there's no one
here that can't understand the Coca-Cola
Company I would say there's no one here
that can understand some new internet
company and I I said at the annual
meeting this year that if I were
teaching a class in business school on
the final exam I would pass out the
information on the internet company and
ask each student to Value it and anybody
that gave me an answer
flunk I don't know how to do
it but people do it every day I mean
it's more exciting I mean if you look at
it like going to the races or something
you know that's that's a different thing
but if you're investing I mean investing
is putting out money to be sure of
getting more money back later you know
at an appropriate rate and to do that
you have to understand what you're doing
it in I mean you have to understand the
business and you can understand some
businesses but not all businesses
yep Warren so you covered half of it
which is trying to understand a business
and buying a business but you also
alluded to getting a return on the
amount of capital you invest in the
business as an investor and and you know
that comes back to to what are you
paying for the business how do you
determine you know what you think is a
fair price to pay for the business it's
a tough thing to decide but it I don't
want to buy into any business I'm not
terribly sure of so if I'm terribly sure
of it it probably doesn't it probably
isn't going to offer incredible returns
I mean why should something that's is
essentially a cinch to do well offer you
40% a year or something like that so we
we don't have huge returns in mind but
we do have in mind never losing anything
and I mean we we bought seiz candy in
1972 Seas candy was then selling 16
million pounds of candy at $1.95 a pound
and it was making two bits a pound or 4
million pre-tax we paid $25 million for
it took no Capital to speak of when we
looked at that business basically my
partner Charlie and I really to decide
whether there was a little untapped
pricing power there in other words
whether that $1.95 box of candy could
just as easily sell for two or two and a
quarter if you could sell for two and a/
qu another 30 cents a pound was was4
mil8 on 16 million pounds which on a 25
million purchase price was fine we
didn't do any you know we've never hired
a consultant in our lives we I mean we
our idea of consulting's G and buy a box
of candy you know need uh but what we
did know was there was that they had
share of Mind in California I mean there
was something special every person in
California had something in their mind
about Seas candy and overwhelmingly was
favorable they had taken a box you know
Valen day and give some girl she'd
kissed them if she' slapped them you
know we'd have no business but but as
long as she kisses them you know that's
that's that's what we want in their mind
seiz candy getting kissed and if we can
get that in the minds of people we can
raise prices and and I bought that in I
bought it 1972 we've raised every year I
raise the price on December 26th I raise
it the day after Christmas so that
everybody because we sell a lot at
Christmas in fact we'll make 60 million
this year we'll sell 30 million pounds
make $2 a pound same business same
formulas same everything 60 million
bucks still doesn't take any capital and
we'll make more money 10 years from now
but of that 60 million we make about 55
million in the three weeks before
Christmas and our company song is what a
friend we have in Jesus I mean it
is it is a good
business but the important thing about
that business is think about it a little
people don't buy most people don't buy
box chocolet to consume themselves they
buy them as gifts you know somebody
somebody's birthday more likely it's a
holiday a Valentine's Day single biggest
day day of the year Christmas is the
biggest season by far but women buy for
Christmas and they plan ahead and buy
over two or three week period men Buy on
Valentine's Day they're driving home we
run ads on the radio you know guilt
guilt guilt guilt you know the guys are
veering off the freeway right and left
and they won't dare go home without a
box of candy when we get through with
them on our radio ads so that
Valentine's Day is the biggest day but
can you imagine going home on
Valentine's Day and our seeg candy is
now 11 bucks a pound thanks to my
Brilliance and and let's say there's
there's candy available at $6 a pound
but you really want to walk in on
Valentine's Day and hand I mean your
wife's got all these favorable images of
the Seas candy over the years and she
sees you and that's the way she thinks
of you during the rest of the year when
you really be got it badly and you walk
in and say honey this year I took the
low bid and then hand her a box of candy
I mean it just isn't going to work so in
a sense it is it's a it's it there's
untapped price it's price it's it's not
price dependent basically think of
Disney I mean Disney is selling we'll
say Home Videos for I don't know what
1695 1895 or whatever all over the
world people and we'll say particularly
mothers in this case have something in
their mind about Disney I mean every
person in this room when you say Disney
has something in their mind about it if
I say Universal Pictures you don't have
anything in your mind you know if I say
20th Century Fox you don't have anything
special in your mind if I say Disney you
got something in your mind and that's
true around the world
now picture yourself with a couple young
kids you know who you want to put away
for a couple hours every day so you get
a little piece of mind and you and you
know if you get them one video they'll
watch it 20 times so you go to the video
store or wherever you buy the video are
you going to sit there and premere you
know 10 different videos and watch them
each for an hour and a half to decide
which one your kid should watch no I
mean let's say there's one there for
$6.95 and the Disney's there for
$17.95 you know if you take the Disney
video You're can to be okay so you buy
it and you don't have to make a quality
decision on something that you don't
want to spend the time to do and so you
can get a little bit more money if
you're if you're Disney and you'll sell
a lot more videos makes it a wonderful
business makes it very tough for the
other guy how would you try to create a
brand DreamWorks is trying but how would
you try to create a brand that competes
with Disney around the world and to
replace the concept that people have in
their minds about Disney with something
that says Universal Pictures you know so
that the mother's going to walk in and
pick out a universal pictures uh video
in preference to a Disney it's not going
to happen no Coca-Cola is associated
with people being happy around the world
where every place they're happy where
Disney World or Disneyland where at the
World Cup will be at the Olympics where
every place where people are happy
happiness and Coco together now you give
me I don't care how much money and tell
me that I'm going to do that with RC
Cola around the world and have five
billion people that have a favorable
image in their mind about RC Cola can't
get done you know and you can f around
with a you can do anything you want to
do you have price discounts on weekends
and everything but you're not going to
touch it and that's what you you want to
have in a business that that's the moat
and you want that moat to widen and if
your seiz candy you want to do
everything in the world to make sure
that the experience basically of giving
that gift leads to a favorable reaction
that means means what's in the box it
means the person that sells it to you
because all our business is done when
we're terribly busy I mean people come
in in those weeks before Christmas or on
Valentine's Day and they're long lines
so at 5:00 in the afternoon some woman
is selling the last person the last box
of candy and that person has been
waiting in line for maybe 20 or 30
customers and if the salesperson Smiles
at that last customer our mode is
widened and if she snars at them our
mode is narrowed we can't see it it's
going on every day but that's the key to
it I mean it's the total part of the
product delivery is having everything
associated with with it say Seas candy
and something pleasant happening and
that's what business is all about yep
what purchasing a company how much
qualitative analysis do you do versus
quanitative analysis and
have you ever bought a company where the
numbers told you not
to those are the best buys the question
is whether have I ever bought a company
where the numbers told me not to and how
much is qualitative and how much is
quantitative the Best Buys have been
when the numbers almost tell you not to
I mean because then you then you feel so
strongly about the product and not just
the fact that you're getting a used
cigar butt cheep that it it it's
compelling I mean I I owned a windmill
company at one time so I I you know
windmills are cigar butts believe
me and I bought it very cheap I bought
it a third of working capital and we
made money out of it but there's no
repetitive money to be earned I mean
there's a one-time profit in something
like that and and it it's just not it's
not the thing to be doing I went through
that phase I mean I bought street car
companies and all kinds of things but uh
in terms of the
qualitative I probably understand the
qualitative the moment I get the phone
call I mean almost every business we
bought has taken five or 10 minutes I
mean in terms of analysis uh and we
bought two businesses this year uh
General ree is you know 18 billion or
some deal I've never been to their home
office yeah I hope it's
there there could be just a few guys and
they say well what what numbers should
we send Buffett this month you know I
can see you know coming in once a once a
month and saying well we'll just tell
him we've got 20 billion in the bank
this month instead of 18 billion or
something but I've never been there I've
and before I bought executive jet which
is fractional ownership of of of of jets
and before bought it I'd never been
there I I bought my family a quarter
interest in the program three years
earlier and I'd seen the service and
seen it develop well and I got the
numbers
but if you don't know enough to know
about the business instantly you won't
know enough in a month or two months I
mean you have to have sort of the
background of of understanding and and
knowing what you do understand and don't
understand and that that is the key it's
it's defining what I call your circle of
competence and everybody's got a
different circle of competence the
important thing is not how big the
circle is the important thing is staying
inside the circle and if that Circle has
only got 30 companies in it out of
thousands on the big board as long as
you know which 30 they are you're okay
and you should know those businesses
well enough so that you don't need to
read do lots of work now I I did a lot
of work in the earlier years just in
getting familiar with businesses and and
the way I would do that is I would go
out and use what Phil fiser called the
scuttlebut approach I'd go out I talk to
customers i' talk to i' talk to to uh
maybe ex employees in some cases I talk
to suppliers everybody every time I'd
see somebody in an industry let's say I
was interested in the coal industry I go
around and see every Coal Company and
I'd ask every every CEO if you could
only buy stock in one coal company that
wasn't your own which one would it be
and why and you piece those things
together and you learn a lot about the
business after a while and funny thing
is you get very similar answers as long
as you ask about competitors that you
know I I say if you got a silver bullet
you know and you put it through the head
of one competitor competitor and why you
know you'll find out who the best guy in
the industry is that in that case or the
one that's coming up and there's so
there's a lot of things you can learn
about a business I I've done that in the
past uh on the businesses that I feel I
could understand so I don't have to do
much of that anymore it's a nice thing
about investing is you don't have to
learn anything very new I mean you can
do it if you want to but if you learned
about regly chewing gam 40 years ago you
you still understand Rish chewing gummy
it's not not a lot of great insights to
get or anything of the sort as you go
along so you do get a database in your
head I had a guy Frank Rooney who ran
Melville for many years his
father-in-law died owned a company
called HH Brown a shoe company and uh he
put it up with Goldman Sachs but he was
playing golf with a friend of mine here
in Florida and uh mentioned to this
friend the guy said why don't you call
warn he called me at the end of the golf
match and in five minutes I basically
had a deal and but I I knew Frank and I
knew the kind of business I sort of knew
the basic economics of a shoe business
and so I could buy it and quantitatively
I got to decide what the price is uh
but uh you know that's either yes or no
I mean I don't I don't fool around a lot
with negotiations so if they if they
name a price that makes sense to me I
buy it if they don't I you know I was
happy the day before so I'll be happy
the day after without owning it yeah
Coca-Cola just announced dropping
expectations in terms of future earnings
and in earnings and in light the fact
that K has a lot of their profits coming
in from outside the United States how do
you think that the Asian crisis so to
speak is going to affect Co for that
matter question is about the Asian
crisis and how it affects a company like
Co that recently announced that the
earnings actually they just announced
the third quarter earnings but a few
weeks ago they tipped people off that
they were going to be lower in the
fourth quarter Z well basically I love
it but but uh because the market for
Coca-Cola products is going to grow far
faster over the next 20 years uh
internationally than it will in the
United States it'll grow in the United
States on a per capita base it's going
to go fter elsewhere so the fact that it
it's going to be a tough period for who
knows 3 months or 3 years but it won't
be tough for 20 years I mean people are
still going to they're you know they're
going to work productively around the
world and they're going to find that
this is a a a bargain product in terms
of uh the portion of their working day
that they have to give up in order to
have one of these or or better yet five
of them a day like I do uh it's a uh you
know this is a product
in 1936 when I first bought six of those
for a quarter and sold them for a nickel
each and it was in a 6 and A2 ounce
bottle and you paid a two 2 cent deposit
on the bottle that was a 6 and2 ounce
bottle for a nickel at that time it's
now a 12 ooun can which if you buy it on
on weekends or if you buy in bigger
quantity so so much money doesn't go to
the packaging me you essentially can buy
the 12 ounces for not much more than 20
cents so you're paying not much more
than twice per ounce price of 1936 and
it is a product that's gotten cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper in Rel relative
to people's earning power over the years
and which people love in in in 200
countries you have the per capita use
going up every year for a product over a
100 years old and the dominates the
market I mean that is it's unbelievable
one thing that people don't understand
is one of the things that makes this
product is worth tens and tens of
billions of dollars is one simple fact
about about really all colas but we'll
call it Coca-Cola for the moment happen
to be a name I like
uh Cola has no taste memory you can
drink one of these at 9:00 11:00 3:00
the afternoon 5:00 the one at 5:00 will
taste just as good to you as the one you
drank early in the morning you can't do
that with cream soda root beer orange
grape you name it all of those things
accumulate on you most foods and and and
and beverages are accumulate on you you
get sick of them after a while and if
you if you eat I mean we get these
people to go to work for us and sees
candy and we tell them they eat all the
candy they want the first day they go
crazy but after a week they're eating
about the same amount they EAS if if
they were buying it because chocolate
accumulates on everything accumulates on
there is no taste memory to Cola and
that means that you get people around
the world that are heavy users that'll
drink five a day or Diet coat maybe you
know seven or eight a day or something
of the sort they'll never do that with
with other products so you get this
incredible per capita consumption the
average person
in in this part of the
world uh well maybe a little north of
here drinks about 64 ounces of liquid a
day and you can have all 64 ounces of
that be Coke and you will not get fed up
with Coke if you like it to start with
in the least but if you do that with
almost anything else if you eat just one
product all day you you'll tend you'll
get a little sick of it after a while
and and and uh it's it's a huge Factor
so that
today over 1 billion 8 ounce servings of
Coca-Cola products will be sold in the
world and that will grow year by year
it'll grow in every country virtually
it'll grow on a per capital basis and 20
years from now it'll grow in a lot
faster internationally than in the US so
I really like that Market Market better
because there there is more growth there
over time but it it will hurt them in
the in the it is hurting him in the
short term right now and but that that
doesn't mean anything I mean it
uh Coca-Cola went public in I think it
was 1919 stock sold for $40 a
share it went back before that as was a
Candler family and they they went back
they bought it for 2,000 bucks the whole
business uh as the Candler back in the
late 1880s and a couple of purchases so
now he goes public in 1919 $40 a share
one year later it's selling for $19 gone
down 50% in one year now you might think
that's some kind of disaster and you
might think that Sugar prices in
inreased and the bottlers were
rebellious and a whole bunch of things
you could always find a few reasons why
that wasn't the ideal moment to buy it
years later you'd have seen the Great
Depression and you'd have seen World War
II and you've seen sugar rationing and
you've seen thermonuclear weapons and
the whole thing there's always a reason
but in the end if you bought one share
for 40 bucks and reinvest the dividends
it' be worth about 5 million now and
that factor so
overrides anything else I if you're
right about the business you'll make a
lot of money and and the timing part of
it is is very is is a very tricky thing
so I don't worry about any given event
if I've got a wonderful business uh you
know whether what it does to next year
something of the sort uh um you know
their price controls have been in this
country at various times and that's
that's followed up even the best of
businesses I mean I wouldn't be able to
raise the price on December 26th of seas
candy if we had price controls and we've
had them in this country but that
doesn't make it a lousy business if that
happens to happen because you're not
going to have price controls forever we
had them in the early in the early '70s
so it it the wonderful business you know
you can figure out what will happen you
can't figure out when it will happen you
don't want to focus too much on when you
want to focus on what if you're right
about what you don't have to worry about
one very much is there an area I'm
missing back there any place just want
to make sure I'm not focusing all of
them on one place let me get this
gentleman over
here most St the most
successful learn less from
what investment mistes you
made
and the question is about my business
mistakes how much time do you
have well the interesting thing about
the mistakes is that in Investments at
least for me and for my partner Charlie
merer the biggest mistakes have not been
mistakes of of commission they've been
mistakes of omission there where we knew
enough about the business to do
something and for one reason or another
we sat there sucking our thumbs instead
of doing something and so we we've
passed up things where we could have
made billions and billions of dollars
from things we understood forget about
things we don't understand we don't fact
I can make billions out of Microsoft
doesn't mean anything because I never
understand Microsoft but if I can make
billions out of healthcare stocks you I
shouldn't make it and I didn't you know
when when when the Clinton Health Care
Program was proposed and they all went
in the tank um we should have made a ton
of money out of that uh because I could
understand it I didn't make it I should
have made a ton money out of Fanny May
back in the mid 80s cuz I understood it
and I didn't do it those are billion
dollar mistakes or multi-billion dollar
mistakes that that generally accepted
accounting principles don't pick up uh
the mistakes you
see the mistakes you see we we made a
isn't we I made a mistake uh buying U US
Air preferred some years ago I mean that
I had a lot of money around I make
mistakes when I get cash Charlie tells
me to go to a bar instead you don't hang
around the office but I I hang around
the office and I got money in my pocket
I do something dumb and it happens every
time and and uh so I I bought this thing
nobody made me buy it I now have a 800
number I call every time I think I
buying stock in an airline and they
talked me down they say you know I say
I'm worn I'm an aholic and then the guy
says you know keep talking don't hang up
you know don't do anything rash and
finally I get over it uh but I but I I I
bought it you know and uh it looked like
we were going to lose all our money in
that and we came very close to losing
all our money and and you can say we
deserve to lose all our money and we
bought it because of it was an
attractive security but it was in not in
an attractive business I did the same
thing with Solomon that I bought an
attractive Security in in a business
that I wouldn't have bought the equity
in so you can say that that's one form
of mistake buying something because you
like the terms when you don't like the
business that well and i' I've done that
in the past I'll probably do it again uh
the the bigger mistakes though are the
ones of all Mission U I did back back
when I when I had the 10,000 bucks I put
$2,000 of it into a Sinclair service
station which I lost so my opportunity
cost that's about 6 billion right now
i' fairly big mistake yeah it makes me
feel good when Berkshire goes down then
because the cost of my Singler station
goes down too my 20% opportunity cost
but I will say this you talk about
learning from mistakes I really believe
it's better to learn from other people's
mistakes as much as possible but uh but
we don't spend any time looking back at
Berkshire uh I've got a partner Charlie
muger we've been Pals for 40 years we
never had an argument we disagree on
things a lot but but we but we don't we
don't have arguments about it and we
never look back we just you know we just
figure there's so much to look forward
to that there's just no sense thinking
about what we might it just doesn't make
any difference I mean you you can only
live life forward and you can learn
something perhaps from the mistakes but
the the big thing to do is stick with
the businesses you understand and so if
there's a generic mistake of of getting
outside of your circle of competence and
you know buying something because
somebody tips you on it or something of
the sort in in an area you don't know
about I mean that you should learn
something from that which is that you
stay with what you can figure out
yourself I mean you really want your
decision making to be by looking in the
mirror and uh saying to yourself I
buying 100 shares of General Motors at
55 because and I mean it's your
responsibility if you're buying it and
there's got to be a reason and if you
can't State the reason you should buy it
if it's because somebody told you about
at a cocktail party not good enough you
know I mean there's just it's got to be
something you know can't be because the
the volume you know the chart looks good
on it or anything like that it's got
it's got to be a reason you'd buy the
business
and we that we stick to pretty pretty
carefully that's one of the things Ben
Graham taught
me
yeah the current genous economic
situation in the world Although our
economy seems to be still jagging along
quite well where are we
what's going to happen with rates the
question about what's going to happen
interest rates where we going in the
world I don't think about the macro
stuff you know I I just um the important
what you really want to do in
Investments is figure out what's
important and knowable if it's
unimportant or unknowable you you forget
about it what you talk about is
important but in my view it's not
knowable understanding Coca-Cola is
knowable or Wrigley or Eastman Kodak or
anything I mean you can understand those
business that's knowable and
whether it turns out to be important
depends on where your valuation leads
you and the current price and all of
that but we have never either bought a
business or not bought a business
because of Any macro feeling of any kind
we don't read things about predictions
about interest rates or business or
anything like that because it doesn't
make any difference I mean let's say in
1972 when we bought Seas candy I think
maybe Nixon put on the price controls a
little bit later let's say we'd seen
that but so what we have missed a chance
to buy something for 25 million that's
60 million pre-tax now I we we don't
want to pass up the chance to do
something intelligent because of some
prediction about something that we're no
good on it anyway so we just don't we
don't read or listen to or do anything
in relation to to macro factors at all
zero and the typical investment
counseling organization goes out and
they give you they bring out their
Economist they Trot them out and he
gives you this big macro picture and
then they start working from there on
down in our view that's nonsense that uh
uh and if if you know if Allen Greenspan
was on one side of me Bob ruin on the
other side they're both whispering in my
ear exactly what they're going to do the
next 12 months wouldn't make any
difference to me and what I pay for
executive jet or general reinsurance or
anything else I
do yeah what's the of being
out well what's the benefit of being an
out of towerer uh as opposed to being in
Wall Street I I worked in Wall Street
for a couple of years and uh and I like
I've got I've got my best friends
actually and I'm both coast and I like
seeing them and I get ideas when I go
there but the best way to get to think
about Investments is to be in a room
with no one else and just think and if
that doesn't work nothing else is going
to work uh and the disadvantage of
being in any kind of a market type
environment in Wall Street would be the
extreme is that you get over stimulated
you think you have to do something every
day I mean the cber family paid 2,000
bucks for this company and that you
don't have to do much else if you pick
one of those and the trick then is not
to do anything else even not to sell it
in 1919 which they the family did later
on it uh so what you're looking for is
some way to get one good idea a year you
know and then and then write it to its
full potential and that's very hard to
do in an environment where people are
shouting prices back and forth every
five minutes and shoving reports under
your nose and all that because Wall
Street makes its money on activity you
make your money on inactivity you know I
mean if everybody in this room trades
their portfolio around every day with
every other person you know you're all
going to end up broke and and and and
the intermediary is going to end up with
all the money on the other hand if you
all own stock in a in a group of average
businesses and just sit here for the
next 50 years you'll end up with a fair
amount of money and your broker will be
broke so his act his
activity is is he's like a doctor who
gets paid out how often he gets you to
change pills I mean basically I mean he
gives you one pill and it cures you the
rest of your life and he's got one sale
one trans transaction and and that's it
but if he can convince you that changing
pills every day is the way to great
health uh it'll be great for him and the
prescription and and you'll be out a lot
of money and you won't be any healthier
be a lot worse off financially so it you
want to stay away from any environment
that
stimulates activity and Wall Street
would have the effect of of doing that
the uh I would I I used when as when I
went out the I'd go back about once
every six months and I'd go back with a
whole list of things I wanted to check
out one way or another companies I
wanted to see and and I would I would
get my money's worth out of those trips
but then i' go back to want and think
about
it yeah how should an investor evaluate
owning shares of B pathway or Microsoft
when they don't pay dividends to invest
yeah well the question with Burkshire
hathway about evaluating birkshire when
it doesn't pay any dividends and it
won't pay any dividends either it uh
it's a promise I can keep uh the uh all
you get with Burkshire you stick it in
your safe deposit box and then every
year you go down and fondle it you know
you take it out and you fond it then you
put it back and I mean there's enormous
psychic reward in that you don't
underestimate it but the the real
question is whether we can keep
retaining dollar bills and turning them
into more than a dollar at at a decent
rate and and that's what we try to do
and and and Charlie Munger and I have
our our money in it to do that that's
all we'll get paid for doing we won't
take any options we won't take any
salaries to pick up or anything we'll
ride around in the plane uh but the uh
that's what we're trying to do it gets
harder all the time the the more money
we manage the harder it is to do that
and we would do way better percentage
wise with Burkshire if it was 1/1 100
the present size but it is it is run for
its owners but it isn't run to give them
dividends because so far every dollar
that we've earned and could have paid
out we've turned into more than a dollar
it's worth more than a dollar to keep it
and therefore it' be silly to pay it out
even everybody was taxfree that owned it
it would have been a mistake to pay
dividends at burshire because so far the
dollar bills retained have turned into
more than a dollar but there's no
guarantee that that happens in the
future and at some point the game runs
out on that uh uh but it is the goal of
I mean that is what the business is
about we're not nothing else about the
business do we judge ourselves by we
don't judge it by the size of its home
office building or you know anything of
the nor people working around there we
got 12 people at headquarters we got
45,000 employees at Burkshire and 12
people at headquarters 3500 ft and we
won't change it so it we will judge
ourselves by the performance of the
company uh and that's the only way we'll
get paid but believe me it's a lot
harder than than it used to be there
anything way in the back because I I
want to make sure I'm not missing people
back there that haven't called okay then
we'll go to the how about way over there
on the on the a yeah what makes you
decide
invest Miss what made me decide to
invest what investment one of your
Investments has reached the school
potential as you said earlier that you
uh I missed the last
part
decide oh reach its full potential well
ideally you buy in businesses where you
feel that will never happen in terms of
I mean I I don't think I don't buy coke
with the idea that it's going to be out
of gas in 10 years you know or 15 years
it I mean there could be something
happened but I I would think that
chances that are almost nil so what we
really want to do is buy businesses that
we would be happy to own forever it's
the same way I feel about people buy
birkshire I want people to buy birkshire
that plan to hold it forever they may
not for one reason or another but I want
them at the time they buy it to think
they are buying a business that they're
going to own forever and I don't say
that's the only way to buy things it's
just that that's the group I want to
have join me because I don't want to
have a changing group all the time I
measure Berkshire by how little activity
there is in it if I if I had a church
and I was the preacher and half the
congregation left every Sunday I
wouldn't say oh this is marvelous cuz I
have all this liquidity among my members
you know you know this terrific turnover
you know uh I would I would I would
rather get a church where all the seats
are filled you know every Sunday by the
same people well that's the way we look
at the businesses we buy we want to buy
something that we're really happy to own
U virtually forever and we can't find a
lot of those and back when I started I
had way more ideas than money so I was
just constantly having to sell what I
thought was the least attractive stock
in order to buy something that I just
discovered that looked even cheaper
but that's not our problem really now
and so we hope we're buying businesses
that we're just as happy with 5 years
from now as as now and if we ever found
some huge acquisition you know then we'd
have to sell something uh maybe to make
that acquisition but that that would be
a very pleasant pleasant problem to have
uh we never buy something with a price
Target in mind I mean we never buy
something at 30 saying if it goes to 40
we'll sell it or 50 or 60 or 100 we just
don't do it that way any more than when
we buy a private business like seize
candy for 25 million we don't say to
ourselves if it ever if we ever get an
offer a 50 million for this business
we'd sell it that that's just not the
way to look at a business way to look at
a businesses is this going to keep
producing more and more and more money
over time and if the answer to that is
yes you don't need to ask any more
questions there is yeah way back
there and um similarly long-term capital
and how did you come up with valuation
well Solomon like I said I was I I went
into that because it was a 9% Security
in 1987 September 1987 we the Dow was up
35% that year we'd sold a lot of stuff
and I had a lot of money around I it
looked to me like we were never getting
a chance to do anything so I took an
attractive security form in a business I
would never buy the common stock of and
I went in because of that and I I think
that's generally a mistake it worked out
okay finely on that but uh but it it
it's not what I should have been doing I
should have I either should have waited
in which case I could have bought more
Coca-Cola a year later thereabouts or I
should have even bought Coke at the
prices it was selling at then even
though it was selling at a pretty good
price at the time so that was a mistake
on long-term uh Capital
that's we have learned other businesses
that are associated with Securities over
the years and I mean one of them is
arbitrage I I I I've done Arbitrage for
45 years and Graham did it for probably
uh 30 years before that
and that's a business unfortunately have
to be near a phone for and I have to I
have to really run out of the office
myself because it it requires being more
sort of Market attuned and I don't want
to do that anymore so I I unless a
really big Arbitrage situation came
along that I understood I won't be doing
much of that but we I probably been in
300 Arbitrage situations at least in my
life maybe more and it's been it was a
good business perfectly good business
long-term capital has a bunch of
positions they got tons of positions but
the top 10 are probably 90 % of the
money that's at risk and I I know
something about those 10 positions I
don't know everything about them by a
long shot but I know enough where I
would feel okay at a big discount going
in and we would have the staying power
to to to hold it out we might lose money
on something like that but the odds are
with us that's a game that I understand
there's a there's a few other positions
we have that aren't that big because
they can't get that big but they involve
they could involve yield curve
relationships or or on the run off the
Run governments or things like that that
are just things you learn over time if
you're around Securities markets they're
not the base of our business probably on
average they've accounted for a half a
percentage point of our return a year
you know or 3/4s of a percentage point a
year of our return they're little pluses
that you get for for actually having
just been around a long time and
learning a little bit about first
Arbitrage not the first Arbitrage I did
but one of the first arbitrages I did
involved a company where you they were
offering cocoa beans in exchange for
their stock that was in 1950 five and I
bought the stock turned in the stock got
Warehouse certificates for cocoa beans
and and they happen to be a different
type they were trading the a Coco
exchange but there was a basis
differential my favorite and I sold them
I mean that's just something that I was
around at the time so I learned about
hasn't been a Coco Bean deal since you
40 odd years I've been waiting for
another cocoa bean deal I haven't seen
it but but it's it's there in my memory
if it ever comes along and that
long-term capital is that on a big
scale yep
the question is about
diversification and I've got a dual
answer to that if you are not a
professional investor if your if your
goal is not to manage money in such a
way as to get a significantly better
return than the world uh then I believe
in extreme diversification I mean if it
so I believe 98 or 99% maybe more than
99% of people who invest uh should
extensively diversify and not trade so
that leads them to an index fund type of
decision with very low costs cuz all
they're going to do is own a part of
America and they made a decision that
only part of America is worthwhile I
don't quarrel with that at all that is
the way they should approach it unless
they want to bring an intensity to the
game to make a decision and start
evaluating businesses but once you're in
the business of evaluating businesses
and and you decide that you going to
bring the effort and intensity and uh uh
and time involved to get that job done
then I think that diversification is a
terrible mistake and to any degree and
uh I got asked that question when I was
at Sun Trust the other day and uh if you
really know businesses you probably
shouldn't known more than six of them I
mean if you can identify six wonderful
businesses that is all the
diversification you need and you're
going to make a lot of money and I will
guarantee you that going into a seventh
one is going to rather than putting more
money in your first one it's got to be a
terrible mistake very few people have
gotten rich on their seventh best idea
but a lot of people gotten rich on their
best idea and so I I
would uh I would say that for anybody
working with normal Capital who really
knows the businesses they've gone into a
six is plenty and uh and I probably have
half of it in what I liked
best I don't diversify personally I mean
and and uh uh all the people I know that
have done well with exception we
mentioned Waller slash earli Waller
diversifies a lot he owns a little of
everything I call him Noah you know he's
got two of
everything yeah how do
youate World from the proor
gamble well Proctor gamble is a good a
very very good business strong
distribution capabilties lots of brand
names and everything but if you ask me
we're going to go away for 20 years to
put all my family's net worth in one
business but I rather have Proctor and
Gamble or Coke actually Pro gam a little
more it' be more Diversified monk
product line but I would feel sure of C
Proctor and Gamble I wouldn't be unhappy
if somebody told me I had to own Proctor
and Gamble during that 20- year period I
mean that would be in my top 5% because
they they are not going to get killed
you know but I would feel better about
the unit growth and the pricing power of
a Coke over 20 or 30 years than I would
about a Proctor and Gamble right now the
pricing power might be tough but you
think of billion billion servings a day
you know an extra Penny $10 million a
day you know we own 8% of it that's
that's $800,000 a day for Birch your
hathway you get another Penny out of the
stuff doesn't seem impossible does it I
mean it's worth another Penny but uh it
doesn't right now it' be a mistake to
try and get it in most markets but over
time Coke will make more preserving than
it does now 20 years from now I'll
guarantee you they'll make more per
serving they'll be selling a whole lot
more servings I don't know how many I
don't know how much more but I know that
uh png's main
products I don't think they have the
kind of dominance and they don't have
the kind of unit growth but they but
they're good businesses you know I I
would not be unhappy uh if you told me
that I had to put my family's net worth
in PNG and that was the only stock I
could own I would you know there I might
prefer some other names but there aren't
a hundred other names I would
prefer y same about McDonald's go away
20 years come back McDonald's the
question is about McDonald's and going
away for 20 years McDonald's has got a
lot of things going for it and
particularly abroad again I mean they
they're position in abroad in many
countries is stronger relatively than
here it's a tougher business over time
people do not want to eat um exception
to the kids when they're giving away
beanie babies or something people do not
want to eat at McDonald's every day I
mean if people are drinking Coke today
they drink five of the day I'll probably
drink five tomorrow uh the the fast food
business is tougher than that it uh but
if you had to pick one hand to have in
the fast food business which is going to
be a huge business worldwide you pick
McDonald's I mean it has the the
strongest position uh it doesn't win
taste tests you know with adults and I
mean does very well with children and it
does fine with adults but it I mean it
is not it is not like it's a clear
winter and uh and it's gotten into the
game in recent years of being more price
Promotional and and you know you
remember the experiment a year ago or so
and uh so it's gotten more dependent on
that rather than just selling the
product by by itself I like a product by
itself sells I I feel better about
Gillette if people buy the Mach 3
because they like the Mach 3 than if
they got a beanie baby with it you know
I mean so I just think it's
fundamentally a stronger product if
that's the case and and uh you know it
probably is we own we own a lot of
Gillette and
and you can sleep pretty well at night
if you think of a couple billion men
with their hair growing on their faces
you go to you know they're it's growing
all night while you sleep you know and
women have two legs it's even better so
it's uh it beat counting sheep I and
those are the kind of business but if
you got think you know what promotion am
I going to put out there against Burger
King next month you know and what if
they sign up Disney and I don't get
Disney and I mean that that is I I like
the I like the products that Standalone
absent promotional pricing appeals
although you can build a very good
business based on that and and
McDonald's is a terrific business it's
not as good a business as as Coke but
that you know there really hard hardly
any uh it's a very good business and if
you bet on one company in that field
aside from Dairy Queen of course you
want to bet on McDonalds we bought Dairy
Queen here a while back that's why
plugging it shamelessly
here yeah way back
there what do I think of
what electric utility industry well i'
i' I've thought about that a lot because
you can put big money in it and and I've
even thought of buying entire businesses
is there's a fellow in Omaha actually
that's that's that's done a little of
that uh uh through Cal energy but I
don't quite understand the game in terms
of how it's going to develop uh uh with
deregulation I mean it's it there's got
to I can see how it destroys a lot of
value uh for the high cost producer you
know once they're not protected by a
monopoly territory and I don't for sure
see how who benefits and how much I mean
obviously the guy with very lowc cost
power some guys got Hydro power you know
2 cents a kilow or something like that
it's got a huge Advantage but how much
of that he's going to get to keep and
everything or how extensively he can he
can send that outside his natural
territory I haven't been able to figure
that out with a so that I really think I
know what the industry is going to look
like in 10 years but it is something I
think about and if I ever develop any
insights you know that call for Action
I'll Dev you know I will act on them but
it because I think I can understand the
attractiveness of the product and it's
it's all of that all the aspects of
certainty of of user need and and and
the fact it's a bargain and all of that
I understand I just don't understand
who's going to make the money in it uh
10 years from now and and that keeps me
away yeah what do you think that the
market is favor the large caps chip
stocks over the small cap stock next
question is large caps versus small caps
and why large caps
overperform I I don't know the answer to
that we we don't
think uh we don't we don't care whether
it's companies large cap giant Cap
Middle cap small cap micro cap doesn't
make any difference I mean the only
question us is can we understand the
business do we like the people running
it and does it sell for a price that is
attractive from our my personal
standpoint running birkshire now because
we've got proa for Gen re I don't know
what we have maybe 75 or 80 billion
dollars to invest and I only want to
invest in about five things so I I'm
really limited to very big companies but
if I were in in
$100,000 I wouldn't care whether
something was large cap or small cap or
anything it I would just look for
businesses I understood
now I I think that on on balance large
cap companies as businesses have done
extraordinarily well the last 10 years
and way better than people anticipated
they would do I mean you really have
American Business
earning close to 20% on equity and
that's something nobody dreamed of and
that's being produced by very large
companies in aggregate so you've had
this
huge revaluation upward of in because of
lower interest rates and then much
higher Returns on Capital and you know
if if American Business is really a bond
disguised bond that earns 20% has a 20%
coupon it's much better than if it's a
bond with a 13% coupon and and that's
that's happened with big companies in
recent years whether it's permanent or
not it's another question I'm I'm
skeptical of that but uh but I don't I I
I I it I wouldn't even think think about
except for questions of how much money
we run I wouldn't even think about the
size of the the business a good small
Seas candy was a $25 million business
when we bought it I mean if I could find
one just like it now even as big as we
are you know I'd love to buy it and uh
just it's the certainty of it that that
that
counts yeah way over there you mentioned
earlier that in buying stock almost
every company's public and one thing
until the last 5 years real estate has
been primarily private we're now seeing
great um securization of real estate and
one is your insights into the yeah you
talking about realate there been
securitization enormous securitization
of of of of of the debt too of real
estate and that is one of the items
right now that is really clogging up uh
the the capital markets I mean the the
mortgage back Securities are they're
just not moving uh in in commercial
mortgage back not Residential Mortgage
back
so that's but I think you're you're
directing your question at equities
probably and and the
equities if you leave out the corporate
form has been a lousy way to own
equities I mean you you've interjected a
corporate income tax into something that
people individually have been
able to own with with a single tax and
by having the normal corporate form you
get a double taxation in there you
really don't need with real estate and
it takes away too much of the return
REITs uh have in effect created a do it
so that you don't get the double
taxation but they also generally have
fairly High operating expenses and if
you if you get real
estate let's just say you can buy fairly
simple types of real estate on an 8%
yield or thereabouts and you take away
maybe close to one or one and maybe even
one and a half% by the time you count
stock options and everything it's not a
terribly attractive way own it maybe the
only way a guy with a th000 bucks or
5,000 bucks can own it but if you have a
million dollar $10 million you're better
off owning the real real estate
properties yourself and sticking some
intermediary in between that will get a
sizable piece U of of the return for
himself
so we have found very little in that
field uh you'll see an announcement in
the next couple weeks that may be lie
what I telling you here I one thing so I
want I don't want you to think I was
double crossing you up here uh but
generally speaking we we've seen very
very little in that field that gets us
excited uh
uh there
people sometimes get very very confused
about they'll look at uh some huge Land
Company uh take I'll take one that's
that
won't evoke any emotional reactions on
the part of anybody like Texas Pacific
Land Trust which has been around over a
hundred years and got a couple million
acres in Texas and they'll take the you
know they'll sell 1% of their land every
year and they'll take that as applying
to everything and come up with some huge
value compared to the market value but
that's nonsense if you really own the
property I mean you you know you can't
move you can't move 50% of the
properties or 20% of the properties it's
it's way worse than a no liquid stock so
you get these I think you get some very
silly valuations placed on a lot of real
estate companies by people that don't
really understand what it's like to own
one and try to move large quantities of
property
uh it re reeks have behaved terribly in
the market this year as you know and
it's not at all inconceivable they would
become a class
that would get so unpopular that they
would sell at significant
discounts uh from what you could sell
the properties for and they could they
could get interesting as a class then
and then the question is whether the
management would fight you in that
process because they would be giving up
their income stream uh for managing
things and their interest might run
counter to the shareholders on that I've
always wondered about the reats and say
you know our our assets are so wonderful
and they're so cheap and then they go
out and sell stock I mean that there's a
there's a contradiction in that if they
say our stock at 28 is very cheap and
then they sell a lot of stock at 28
lesson underwriting commission doesn't
you know they either there dis there's a
disconnect there and so but it's a field
we look at I mean Charlie and I can
understand real estate and uh
and we would be open for very big
transactions periodically and if there
was a long-term Capital Management
situation and translated to real estate
you know we would be open to that
trouble to so many other people would be
too that it would be unlikely to go at a
price that would that would really get
us
excited way back there understanding
your theory that sort of a Down Market
is good for net Savers you could you
sort of give us your thoughts as to
where the Market's going it's downward
Trend longterm Prof longterm obious well
I yeah I've got no idea where the
Market's going to go I prefer it going
down but I but I have you know my
preferences have nothing to do with it
they the market knows nothing about my
feelings uh you that's one of the first
things you have to learn with a stock
you know you buy 100 shares at General
Motors now all of a sudden you have this
feeling about General Motors I mean if
it goes down you may be mad at it you
may say well if it just go up to what I
paid for it you know my life will be
wonderful again or if it goes up you may
say how smart you were and how you and
General Motors had this love affair and
everything you've got all these feelings
stock doesn't know you own it stock just
sits there it doesn't care what you paid
it doesn't care that you owned it or
anything so any feeling I have about the
market is not reciprocated I mean it is
the
ultimate yeah it is it is very cold
shoulder we're talking about here and
anybody that is going to be a net sa
practically everybody in this room is
more likely to be a net buyer of stocks
over the next 10 years than they are a
net seller so every one of you should
prefer lower prices I mean if you're
going to be a net Eater of hamburger in
the next 10 years you want hamburger to
go down unless you're a Catt cattle
producer and if you're going to be a
buyer of Coca-Cola and you don't own
Coke stock you hope Coke the price of
coke goes down I mean you're looking for
it to be on sale this weekend at your
Supermarket you want it to be down on
the weekends not up on the weekends when
you're going to attend the supermarket
New York Stock Exchange is a big
supermarket companies and you're going
to be buying stocks what do you want to
have happen you want those stocks to go
down way down and uh you know you will
make better buys then and later on 20
years from now 30 years from now when
you're in a period when you're dissaving
or when you're airs dis saved for you
after you're gone I mean that then you
may care about higher prices but I I
find people that that was one of the
there's a chapter eight in Ben Grahams
intelligent investor about the attitude
toward stock market fluctuations and
that and the chapter 20 on the margin of
safety are the two most important essays
ever ever written on investing as far as
I'm concerned because when I read
chapter 8 when I was 19 I I figured you
know I mean what I what I just figured
out what I just said but it was it's
obvious I didn't figure it out myself
though it was it was explained to me I'd
probably gone another hundred years if I
had still thought it was good when my
stocks were going up uh now we want we
want things to go down but I have no
idea what the stock market's going to do
I never do I never will it it not
something that that I think about at all
when it goes down I feel I look harder
at what I might buy that day uh because
I know there's more likely to be some
merchandise there that I can use my
money effectively
in okay um Warren we'll take one more
question from the audience okay I'll let
you pick who gets it then you could be
the
[Laughter]
guy what's the question okay right back
there uh if you you uh uh maybe again uh
studing your life again then what would
you like to do to uh to have a happier
life yeah I would say and this is going
to sound disgusting question is what
would I do if I going to live over again
to have a happier life uh well I only
thing I might do is select a genan pool
where people live to be 120 or something
I came from
but I've I've been I've been
extraordinarily lucky I mean it it uh I
use this example I'll take a minute or
two because I think it's worth thinking
about a little bit let's just
assume that it
was 24 hours before you were born and a
genie came to you and he said uh he said
herb uh you look very promising and I've
got a big problem I've got to design the
world in which you're going to live and
he said I decided hell with it's too
tough you design it so you got 24 hours
you figure out what the social rules
should be the economic
rules uh the governmental rules and
you're going to live under those your
kids are going to live under them your
kid their kids are going to live
under and you say I can design anything
and jnie says yeah you can do it and you
say Well there must be a catch he says
well there is a catch you don't know
whether you're going to be born black or
white rich or poor male or female uh
infirm or able-bodied bright or
all you know is you're going to take one
ball out of a barrel that's got 5.8
billion you're going to participate in
what I call the ovarian Lottery you're
going to get one ball out of there and
that's and that is the most important
things ever going to happen to you in
your life cuz that is going to control
whether you're born here or in
Afghanistan or whether you're born with
an IQ of 130 or an IQ of 70 uh it's
going to determine a whole lot and
you're going to go out of the world and
you're going to have that ball what kind
of a world do you want to design well I
think that's a good way to look at
Social question because not knowing
which ball you're going to get you're
going to want a ball that you're going
to want a system design a system that's
going to produce lots of goods Services
because you're going to want people on
balance to live well and you're going to
want it that produces more and more so
your kids live better than you do and
your your grandchildren live better than
the kids but you're also going to want a
system that if it does produce lots of
goods and services does not leave behind
a person that accidentally got the wrong
ball and is not well-wired for this
particular system see I'm I'm ideally
wired for the system I fell into here I
mean I came out and I got something
enables me to allocate Capital you know
nothing so wonderful about that if all
of us were stranded on a desert island
you know we all landed there we never
going to get off of it the most valuable
person would be the one that could raise
the most rice you know uh over time and
and you know I could say well I going to
allocate Capital you how about pay
meal and you wouldn't get very excited
about that so I am in the right place I
mean gate says if I'd been born you know
a few million years ago I'd in some
animals lunch you know he says you can't
run very fast you can't climb trees you
can't do anything just mean you know
just been chewed up in the first day so
he says you're lucky you were born today
and I and I am but but the question
getting back one question you can ask
yourself incidentally is here is this
barrel with 5.8 billion balls everybody
in the world if you could put your ball
back and they gave you and then they
took out at random a hundred other balls
and you had to pick one of those would
you put your ball back in now those 100
Balls that you're going to get
out
roughly uh five of them will be American
so there 95 versus is five so you're
only going to have five ball if you want
to be in this country you're only going
to have five balls now left you know
half of them are going to be women half
of them going to be men I'll let you all
decide how you vote on that one uh half
of them are going to be below average
intelligence half are going to be above
mean do you want to put your ball back
most of you I think will not want to put
that ball back to get a 100 so what
you're saying is I'm in the luckiest 1%
of the world right now right now sitting
in this room top 1% of the world well
that's the way I feel I mean I've been
lucky to be born where I was to it was
50 to1 against me in in the United
States when I was born lucky with
parents lucky with all kinds of things
then lucky to be wired in a way that in
a market economy pays off like crazy for
me doesn't pay off for somebody who's
absolutely as good a citizen as I am you
know leading Boy Scout Troops teaching
Sunday school whatever raising fine
families but it just doesn't happen to
be wired in the same way I am so I've
been extremely lucky so I would like to
be lucky again and and if I'm
lucky then the way to do it is to play
out that game and and and and do
something you enjoy you know all your
life and be associated with people you
like I only work with people I like you
know I I don't I don't if I could make
aund Million by buying a business with
some guy that caused my stomach to churn
I'd say no because I say that's just
like marrying for money which probably
isn't a very good idea in any
circumstances but if you're already rich
it's crazy
right I am not going to marry for
money so I would do I would I would
really do almost exactly uh what I've
done except I don't think got a bought
the US Air thanks